Joran
[Music]
for the past 10 years the reality TV
show shark tank has entertained
identified millions of viewers by
dramatizing how entrepreneurs pitch
venture capitalist and none of the
Sharks the investors who compete with
each other to fund businesses they think
might be successful is more entertaining
or edifying than Kevin O'Leary whose
signature insult to unsuccessful
contestant you're dead to me has become
a pop culture company you're dead to me
and you are as I'm out but O'Leary isn't
just the small screen blowhard born and
raised in Canada the 65 year old
investor got rich by developing
educational and family-oriented computer
software in the 80s and 90s you kids
should keep the guts to lose that be
holding firm to a gospel of thrift
savings and reinvestment that he's
outlined in best-selling books such as
cold hard truth on men women and money
over the years he's diversified his
investments into vineyard storage
facilities of much more and he's dabbled
in politics too briefly considering a
run in 2017 to head the Conservative
Party in his native Canada Justin
Trudeau is going to elect Kevin O'Leary
he just has to keep doing what he's
doing he's incompetent his brash nature
earned him easy comparisons to Donald
Trump
but O'Leary who lives now in Boston is
openly free trade and Pro immigration
he's also long been in favor of
marijuana legalization and gay rights
and opposed to military interventionist
reason sat down with O'Leary at Freedom
Fest the annual gathering of
libertarians in Las Vegas we talked
about why he thinks shark tank is so
popular why Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau is so bad and whether
democratic socialism is really a threat
to the free market capitalism that he
says makes us richer and happier we also
talked about why he thinks Donald Trump
has been great for the economy despite a
personal style he finds unappealing
freedom
that's what my name is kevin o'leary
thanks for talking to reason great to be
here thank you what explains shark
tank's immense appeal I mean you guys
you've been on for 10 seasons you've
last season you're averaging something
like five and a half million people per
show there's the larger Dragons Den
phenomenon which inspired it was I mean
you were on that in candidates in other
countries why do people like Shark Tank
so much you know I think a lot of what's
happened here was a surprise originally
to the format owners Sony Mark Burnett
and MGM and certainly Disney owns ABC we
had no idea this would happen and indeed
for the first three years the show was
right on the bubble whether it would be
continued or not and then it went
geometric in its fourth season exploded
you know I always tell people what are
you watching when you're watching shark
tank because you know I I taped those
episodes and I watch it too because I'm
always interested to see how the editors
cut that one-and-a-half hour pitch down
to eight minutes you're watching the
pursuit of freedom and it's a visceral
powerful thing to watch people have
dreams and pursue them and every once in
a while we make millionaires not all the
time it's very hard to run a business
but but we've made many many
millionaires on Shark Tank and that is
extremely visceral and powerful and
magnetic and our fastest-growing
demographic
demographic right knows 9 to 18 year old
women and who would have ever thought
that would happen I always think of it
too as it's it's kind of like Ben
Franklin's autobiography where he's
explaining to his son you know this is
how I made my way in the world you're I
mean you're demystifying how you start a
business or what goes into a business
variation how hard it is to run a
business and how difficult and how
challenging and how a life changer it is
and it's not easy and people are
understanding the entrepreneurial
journey is not for everybody but for
those that are pursuing it they're
extremely interested you practice a kind
of former you embody a form of
capitalism and entrepreneurship with
without romance you say you know what
are the numbers you're dead to me
you know I want money where does that
come from I'm a little right-wing of
Attila the Hun and I believe that
business the DNA of a business is to
provide to its
constituents clearly customers come
number one number two employees
somewhere in there are the shareholders
and lastly you who started it you're the
last but when you try and shift a
business's true purpose and say that
it's going to save society you will fail
not some of the time 100% of the time
saving baby whales is not what
businesses do and now as people trying
to contort them to do that they will
find out and we have this debate I teach
a lot of graduating cohorts of engineers
and business students and this is the
primary debate we have is when you go
out into the world if you think your job
is to solve all of society's problems
you will get fired unless you start
delivering value to customers and
shareholders and employees the rest of
the world that's not your problem your
problem is taking care of your business
we're speaking at Freedom Fest in Las
Vegas an annual convention you're here
to debate John Mackey with it looking
CEO and yeah of holder he talks about
conscious capitalism and and the model
he puts for it he's very successful as
well what what's wrong with that idea of
conscious capitalism where he seems to
talk and and now that I actually the way
you're talking man he talks about
multiple stakeholders but he also says
you know profit comes first because
without profit there's nothing but
what's wrong with a kind of fuzzier form
of capitalism in fact if you read
Mackey's principles the four pillars
that he espouses much of what he's
talking about our important management
skills and I agree with him on that
where he gets lost and well we'll have
the core of our debate today is in the
greater purpose because think about this
problem you have a phenomenally
successful business that is global and
you're you decide that you have a cause
that you want to be an environmentalist
or you want to save a certain part of
society or there's some medical disease
you want to give to as a CEO why does
the constituency where headquarters
matter why doesn't the customer base in
India or in China or if you are trying
to do something sustainable that may be
irrelevant to customers in Cambodia and
so that's why it becomes really
difficult to pursue mandates that are
outside of the core principles of
growing profits and the
or you take shareholders from capital
and redeploy it away from their pockets
the higher your cost of capital is going
to be because shareholders and I'm an
investor I covet managers that deliver
me high returns with low risk that's
what the whole core of capitalism is and
when you try and say it's something else
not only is it dangerous
but you're 100% wrong that's not how it
works we have 200 years of proof that
that's how it doesn't work are you are
you anti philanthropy or it's so it's
more that you make your money in
business and then when you have your
causes or your wealth you can help with
that let me give you an example let's
say I can invest in two financial
services companies and one of them
decides the CEO decides that he wants to
support a charity and he wants to give
100 million dollars to that charity
across four quarters now it's not my
charity my family supports multiple
charities but none of the ones that I
support he is supporting my message to
him or her is you deliver me my profits
I will decide which charities I want to
support you have no right to do that on
my behalf I don't agree with you I don't
care what you like you should take your
portion of your salary or the stock you
own and the dividends you get and you
deploy it the way you want the core of
the business is to deliver profits to
the shareholders who then will redeploy
it in any way they wish and when you
lose that mandate when you when you
misunderstand that I'll fire you if I'm
a shareholder that's what I want to do
in preparing for this I've read a and
watched a bunch of energy's with you you
are a big defender of capitalism what
what is the best defense of capitalism
as a economic and cultural system it
provides a standard of living for
society in a way that has never been
done before in the history of mankind
there was a time when the majority
people on earth were illiterate and they
were starving and capitalism changed all
of that and certainly John admits that
in his own writing sure and now we're
trying to do capitals in 2.0 when
there's nothing wrong with capitalism
1.0
volatility is inherent in a capitalist
society there are haves and have-nots
there's those that are very good at
entrepreneurship and get end up with
more because they solve more problems
and some people have a problem with that
but the capitalism can't fix that
there's nothing you can do anytime you
attempt to redistribute wealth outside
of the bounds of the capitalistic
mandate countries like Canada are
flailing as a result of that socialism
doesn't work we know that already
you could end up like Cuba but are you
are you then are you like Ebenezer
Scrooge and we're you know are there no
poor houses when you say redistribute
what what's the limit of do you believe
in a social safety net
I do actually I think it's the role of
government to provide basic services I
look at all the different models I
travel the world I'm particularly fond
of what they do in Switzerland where
they basically have multiple tiers of
things like health care and and support
for those that are poor but what they do
is they'll say ok if you're a wealthy
Swiss citizen in the canton of Geneva
and vole and you want to get an MRI
because you want one tomorrow morning at
ten o'clock
you're going to pay for it they're gonna
take the proceeds of that and they're
going to redeploy it into purchasing
more MRI machines so that the social
safety net for those that aren't as
fortunate can get free MRIs I'm a big
advocate of that in Canada where they
try and make everybody equal a dog gets
an MRI first before a human it's absurd
people wait months for hip replacements
for cataract surgery it's a disaster if
you have had you have catastrophic
illness there yes you jump to the head
of the queue the only other way you can
get medical services to buy it in
basically an illicit scheme which I
think is outrageous so to me I'm a huge
advocate of social nets the British have
a good one the the Danish the Finnish
the Swiss the Germans have done well do
you think the American social safety net
works it's under stress right now
because it manifests itself in in
ever-increasing federal debt and so
there has to be a modification to the
health care system here
and there's met there's multiple ways
this can be achieved
I think digitization of medical records
in a true form will help a lot I think
it'll be the focus of the next cycle
whoever ends up being president is gonna
have to deal with it it is not perfect
but not nothing's perfect but as a
society and a market for entrepreneurs
there's no place on earth like the
United States so capitalism is really
under attack right now and it's from
from right-wing populists like you know
Tucker Carlson and Fox News who says oh
well it's good at building new iPhones
and game consoles but really what what
purpose does that serve and then you
have people democratic social or Donald
Trump who is anti free trade he's
anti-free speech which is a part of a
free economy then you have Alexandria
Kaiser Cortez and her social justice
squad that is attacking and are you
worried about capitalism survival no I'm
not inherent in capitalism is not only
volatility of asset prices but
volatility of political mandates and so
in an election cycle that is as visceral
and partisan as we have now I mean you
have a circus going on and it's just the
nature of what Washington is turned into
by the way I think it's a carnival freak
show not a circus is a circus sometimes
it's fun well I I enjoy the rhetoric
it's very entertaining it's not mean
enough for you though I mr. wonderful I
want to bring back I was I'm a huge
history buff and I really enjoyed
history throughout my entire education
and I had a great history teacher when I
was very young in high school and she
taught me something very very important
that I've never forgot in my in my
career and I'll give it to you here
great politicians great leaders great
CEOs are phenomenal entertainers going
back to the days of Alexander the Great
Napoleon Bismarck they used to hold
counsel at night have big dinner parties
or sit around the fire with their camp
with their with their men and tell
stories
they would tell stories of great defeats
great battles great loves and that would
spread through the troops you know the
leader told us about this this maneuver
in the Nile yesterday and it would
capture the hearts and minds of the
people
Donald Trump is exactly that he is a
great entertainer he smoked the
competition by eating 101 percent of the
airtime in the last election unfortunate
for Hillary she was boring on television
and like Obama was it was a different
time she didn't see that it was time to
be entertaining the best ever
coverage she got was the debates with
Trump where it was so mesmerizing I
actually watched that instead of
football I remember sitting with a bunch
of guys golfing and we turned that on
instead of a football game and I said
wow he's Alexander the Great
what do you but you're also you you're
critical of Trump in various ways and
what do you tell her great entertainer
and that allowed him to become the
leader of America and maybe the free
world if we still talk about things in
those terms but you you know looking at
you you had thought about running to be
the head of the Conservative Party in
Canada you're um one of the things you
were talking about and obviously you're
off Canada now you don't like it as much
well that's not true well yeah okay but
you you know you're in favor of more
immigration you are in favor of gay
rights and trans rights and legal weed
you are non interventionist generally in
foreign policy what do you think of
Trump substantively you know you have to
differentiate and my take on Trump and
his his cabinet is I don't watch the
circus or the freakshow whatever you
want to call it I look at the policy I'm
a policy wonk
and I have this unique index I should
share with you I have interests in
almost you know it is over 50 it's over
50 private companies now all practically
every state very few states who know I'm
interested in now
I get the monthly cash flows of every
one of these businesses because most of
my deal structures or royalties as you
know or venture debt or preference
shares or converts and I have lots of
companies around cash flow I have never
in my life seen an economy like this
this is even better than the 60s it is
phenomenal and I think primarily because
of deregulation not tax reform my
companies in California in Texas in
Florida in Illinois in in the municipal
level and the state level have been set
free what is the nature of that
deregulation give me an example give an
example in California had a deal that
converted strip malls
you know retail space it failed 12 min
square feet and turned it into a place
where you could paint and drink wine and
very successful business called wine and
design you've got a painting lesson you
sip wine with your friends you enjoy
yourself for four hours you do a
painting the regulations to actually
allow people to do that included such
absurd regulations for example a frosted
glass window had to be within 21 feet of
a back door that did not have frosted
glass but had bars across it and all
kinds of absurd regulations have been on
the books since the 50s well Trump swept
all that garbage away how did he do that
where they he basically anything that
has a federal mandate he just ripped it
up and some of these regulations were
federally mandated and others were
stripped away by states watching
businesses leave and saying wait a
minute if they're deregulating that for
Texas federally I'm going to do that in
the state basis all of a sudden I can
open up stores all across California
where I never could just like that and
so this has been a really interesting
time over the last thirty six months and
I see no slowdown I just saw last
month's numbers Wow
I mean I'm just so now you're making me
think it's the fall of 1929 I don't know
it's like no I think I can only keep
going up I'm very optimistic about the
domestic economy we could have trade war
issues with the sp500 because 46 percent
of their sales are international but
I'll tell you this about Trump here's my
assumption the chance he doesn't get a
second
my view is zero and I'll tell you why I
don't recall in modern times when going
into a second term at full employment
the incumbent of any party has ever lost
their mandate ever how important to you
and I want to come to Canada in a second
but as in a leader like trumpet but
entertaining etc but then the rhetoric
is not just bilious I mean it's racist
it's extremely divisive and of course
you know people on the other side are
giving him the same does that kind of
stuff trouble you at all or is that just
a kind of epiphenomena that doesn't
matter you know I met Trump because we
both worked for Mark Burnett and he was
on the apprentice we were just starting
shark tank we used to meet up when we
were selling the forwards in New York
he's an advertising for the network's in
many ways his his style is to 50% of the
population his style is difficult he I
don't believe he's a racist man I don't
think I don't believe that at all I
don't think he's a sexist man I don't
believe that at all even though it's
interpreted I think he's a family man
but people don't get that all he's had
several families he he's a and that's
not gonna change is my point
this won't get better for people who
don't like him I ignore all that stuff
and you know I get in in my in my family
the night that he got elected I told we
were all sitting around it was you know
culmination of all that entertainment on
me of the election cycle and my daughter
wept and I said Savannah this is a
really good thing that just happened you
just don't know it yet
she said how can that man be elected how
can you know it was a very divisive
moment in my family so we have in my own
family people that are dining
discussions that you know Sunday night
dinners are about politics I love
politics and I keep trying to sell them
on the merits of his policy and I
realize it's never gonna change their
opinions America is like that too like
my family is just like the average
American family
so with younger people in particular
there's a ton of polls out there showing
you know that Millennials are people
under 40 Americans under 40 have a
positive view of social
some in some polls a more positive view
of socialism than capitalism how do you
change that because you know they are
gettin there's already more Millennials
than baby boomers though they're gonna
be voting at some point where are they
wrong and how do you reach them not you
know to convert them to capitalism I was
a socialist when I was 18 years old - I
was left-wing I tell I got my first
paycheck and I saw something called tax
on it
everybody's a socialist when they're
young until they start working and they
start realizing how tough it is out
there and they start realizing how much
money government wastes when they take
half their income in taxes and that's
when you become a conservative the older
you get the more realistic you become
and a majority of those people make the
transition in their mid-20s that's what
happens I never worry about you my job
today is to teach young people about the
entrepreneurial journey to make sure
that those that can't handle it don't
try it I tell people this is what it's
like I'm gonna give I'm gonna do a
two-hour lecture I'm gonna walk you
through what your life is gonna be like
if you pursue this and maybe some of you
should be great employees because not
everybody in this room is gonna make it
as an entrepreneur it's that way about
life and I think the natural cycle is
the worlds that come by our place when
your parents are paying for everything
for you and then you get out of the
house and you're on your own and you go
wow it's tough out here I read an
interesting story about your childhood
and about your mother you're of Lebanese
and Irish descent and when your mother
died you found out that she had been
investing yeah what was the lesson that
you know that you learned from that and
you know should everybody kind of adapt
that or at least take it seriously the
lesson I learned was that she she had a
fierce desire for financial independence
she had been married twice and she
didn't want a man to rule her life
financially ever and she was a very
shrewd investor she had a portfolio of
23 large cap dividend paying stocks and
telco bonds and over a 50-year period
that portfolio beat every single manager
I'd ever hired she just believed in
owning securities that return capital
shareholders and she would only spend
the
interest and dividends and never the
principal and the principal over that 50
year period appreciated wildly and you
know what what it taught me was to focus
here's how it manifests itself in my
life today
not some of my returns 95% of them in
this 11 year 14 year journey on Dragon's
Den and Shark Tank have come from
companies run by women they are very
very good at mitigating risk and my
mother was like that so now I'm almost
sexist in the sense that even the
producers have to say to me you gotta
invest in some guys I said why
they don't make any money these women
made me all this money look at all these
deals I've made so much money and why
should I take risks with men who can't
dope who have testosterone sales targets
they never had and all the rest of that
stuff so I'm very biased about people
that understand financial independence
that's women mitigate risk that's women
know how to manage time that's women set
reasonable goals have very sticky
cultures in their business that's all
women so I'm telling my guys now every
year we do a big conference in South
Beach I bring all my companies together
50 60 70 people in that room and I say
this is what these women did this year
and this is what you guys did now why
don't you exchange ideas here because I
want all of you to succeed I'm aligned
with you I've risk capital with you go
figure out what they're doing you at
times and flirted with what I would
consider Canadian exceptionalism that
Canada was a great country and that it
was doing a lot of things rights you
know according to various kinds of
indexes of economic freedom Canada is in
many ways more free than the United
States but you're really off Canada you
you pulled all your money out of Canada
you've left I mean you're I guess you're
are you still a Canadian citizen or both
Irish and Canadian okay and so what
happened was in the last election I'm
always willing to give a politician a
chance regardless of where they came
from or how they got their mandate and
in Canada they have the parliamentary
system and so when the current prime
minister was elected I'm like everybody
else and I wished him the best of luck
and hope that when you saw him wearing
that horrible neighbors
or whatever and well his mandate has
been an unmitigated disaster and not
only because of his lack of managerial
skills but he put in place in a
parliamentary system the mandates of
Foreign Affairs or infrastructure
spending or military procurement or
finance are really important because
there are little mini Prime Minister's
the men and women that get those jobs
and he brought in a covenant he was a
very interested in in in providing a
broad diverse but never put competency
in any of his metrics of measuring who
should get these jobs for example he put
in place a journalist in the role of
Foreign Affairs what's happened never in
Canada's history have we upset so many
partners Saudi Arabia Japan Russia China
United States all our prime trading
partners in the last few months and I'll
give you an example and why I was so
happy to have taken my money out when
they started to realize he can't manage
anything the worst countries who have
invested in in the last four years has
been Canada of the g7 a disaster
you will anywhere else would have been
better including Europe the Canadian
dollars collapsed it's gone down for
parity down to 73 cents so you've lost
you twenty four percent right there but
let me give you an example that because
it brings together the idea of
understanding negotiating tactics and
managerial skill when Trump decided to
ramp up the trade war with China when he
really wanted to slap on that second set
of tariffs he was I'm speculating here
but I think I'm right he was really
worried that all of a sudden the Chinese
would cut off trade in agriculture trade
and resources trade and energy trade in
wood where would they all go up to
Canada that would have been a huge win
for Canada what does he do he realizes
he calls up the finance minister in
Canada says the huawei CFO the daughter
of the founder he's going to be in
Vancouver for 32 minutes transferring to
Mexico City arrest her
he totally played Trudeau in the end the
Foreign Affairs Minister like a fiddle
and screwed the country when the Chinese
heard that happened within hours they
cut off ties with Canada
honing threatening to kill two Canadians
that are prison over there
no pork sales anymore no energy no coal
no nickel no steel no wheat nothing
going out of Canada to China
what a brilliant move except if you're a
Canadian citizen or an investor are
Canadian you know taxpayer you realize
you just got snookered by a really smart
guy and a really incompetent finance
minister it's not her fault she's a
journalist she never she was never a
diplomat the poor woman I feel sorry for
her she'll be gone in a few weeks that's
what I did you mentioned before that
capitalism is volatile one of the risks
and this is the economist like Joseph
Schumpeter would talk about this this is
the whole idea of capitalism is built on
creative destruction and there's you
know industries rise and fall with an
individual's lifetime individual
lifetimes and why not that creates a lot
of anxiety and a lot of social
instability people worry you know I'm
working here in this business it might
not be around in five years or this
whole sector might not be do you worry
about that or what are the ways that
capitalism and capitalist societies
free-market societies can mitigate that
kind of dislocation so that you don't
get calls from Democratic socialists to
say we need Medicare for all we need
universal basic income we need a social
safety blanket that covers everything
and smothers entrepreneurship the best
way to dissipate fear is study history
this is why I do it to this day I keep I
keep going farther back and back with
the writings of great leaders from the
past and if you look at history in as
capitalism over the last 200 years has
destroyed many industries and reborn
others 40 years ago you couldn't have
ever dreamt that someone who sat in
front of a screen and wrote code would
make half a million dollars a year in
their first job that didn't exist today
it's engineering it's it's probably the
best job you can get and in 40 years
from now or 20 years or 10 years they'll
you know talking about robots replacing
pizza makers or cooks and all that
I hope it happens because there'll be a
new sector that emerges as a results of
this men will never and women will never
be replaced by machines because they'll
always be finding new purpose in new
problems being solved and I trust in
destructive capitalism to do that I
don't fear any innovation at all
I fear regulation I fear burdensome
government I fear that a third of every
dollar raised by government through
taxes is wasted in every capital society
Canada it's 50 cents on every dollar
United States is about 33 the less money
you give government the better your ad
gets there's new cancer therapies that
starve tumors very effective and very
interesting research going on they're
starving government of funds would be a
good thing
so you mentioned before that in America
you know it's that the system isn't
where the social safety net isn't
working that well but it doesn't stop
the government from just spending more
money and borrowing more money we're 22
trillion dollars in debt why is the debt
a negative why is the debt a problem and
how do we how do we reduce the debt or
so you know because we've been starving
the beast in America for my entire
lifetime but the the Beast this seems to
have a credit card that never gets cut
off well as a percentage of GDP the debt
has been manageable and also we're
moving to a world of zero interest rates
which we already have in Europe then you
think that's no idea around I mean like
yeah why why we haven't any pressure in
the last 10 years that's been a straight
decline of the tenure cost of money the
reason that we may get out of this mess
is that through innovation and
entrepreneurs and technology and a
really robust economy we keep getting
more productivity we keep inventing
things like the internet and the cloud
services that make productivity continue
to perform we keep getting better at
what we do and as a result the economy
continues to grow in terms of its total
size and GDP you know or debt to GDP
remains constant even though the absent
debts going up so I can take and you can
take a little bit of solace in that now
do I like the fact that government
wastes a third of every dollar and
that's my number we can debate it till
the cows come home no I don't and and so
I'm into this mode of saying how do you
starve government of money because that
is an interesting idea basically the
money's not going to worth staying in
the economy people are reinvesting in
creating jobs which is way better than
what government does all the stupid
things they waste money on because they
have no accountability and I think in
the next 10 years 15 20 years we're
gonna solve for that in Switzerland it's
illegal to have debt in your Kent on you
go to jail for that they solved the
decades ago Swiss don't run deficits
they don't provide services they can't
afford and every time they want to
provide a new service they actually do a
vote of the entire country and ask for
it
8.2 million people it's profoundly
efficient we could learn from them do
you worry at all about the authoritarian
capitalist model that uh you know a
number of people in the in the 70 or I
guess in the 80s people were talking
about how Japan had figured out how to
manage capitalism in a way you know
growth with that end that ended poorly
for Japan not so much for the US China
now is seen as a model you know and they
figured it out and it's an authoritarian
capitalism do you think China can
continue to lock down or try to try and
screw down more and more parts of the
economy or is that kind of doomed to
failure over the long run if it remains
in its constant model it'll look good
it's doomed to fail if you're you know
leader for life over there which she's
hoping is you need to morph yourself
into a global participant that plays by
the rules I do a lot of business in
China
through manufacturing there most of my
companies we've moved a lot to Vietnam
in the last three years not because of
trade wars because Vietnam became a lot
cheaper not some cheaper 30% cheaper so
we've moved quite a few there and that's
been happening for years now but China
wants to play with the big boys and in
order to do that two things are going to
have to happen it's going to be painful
for them to get
there but I need the ability to protect
my IP in the legal system there because
I need to be able to litigate when when
my IP has been stolen I need an easy
path to stop it as we have here Chinese
investors have come here use our legal
system to raise capital they and stop
you know IP loss we need the same and
the other one and this is why the market
doesn't correct even as Trump raises the
heat on China the middle class there is
like investing in America in 1930 it's
going to be phenomenal do business with
with middle-class Chinese people I have
so much stuff to sell them I can't wait
until this thing gets resolved because
it is going to take US companies to the
next level there's so much they want
from us from entertainment media and
content right through all the technology
we have once it's protectable we'll be
selling it to them that coexistence is
going to be very powerful up leg and
save China it's going to save China it's
going to make it a not an emerging
economy anymore it's going to make it a
mega powerhouse and I believe in the
next 20 years
it will outpace the American GDP but
only if it opens up and becomes more
transient it will it will because they
actually can't afford what's happening
there now there's they're really
starting to suffer particularly as
companies say I don't want to go through
all that headache of tariffs I'm just
going to delay my capital expenditure of
China so the government has to do it all
that's a very dangerous I'd say they're
gonna come to the table in the next two
years we're gonna leave it there thank
you so much thank you and we'll enjoy
we've been talking with Kevin O'Leary of
shark tank this has been reason TV I've
been Nick Gillespie
[Music]